in the wake of their commissioner being
forced to stand down the sarah everard
murder by a serving officer allegations
of sexism and homophobia at charing
cross police station the criticism for
the uk's biggest police force keeps
coming
no one was convicted of daniel morgan's
murder 35 years ago but the alleged
corruption that surrounded the case led
to decades of scrutiny of london's
police and today the police inspectorate
found after 35 years the lessons have
not been learned
the key finding is that they're just not
taking it seriously enough
there is too much that goes wrong with
some pretty basic procedures
that we don't think the met are doing
all they can to minimize the risk of
corruption getting a hold in the force
as it has in the past
the inspectorate found in the last two
years the met has recruited more than
100 people who've committed offences and
failed to properly supervise these
people hundreds of items such as drugs
cash and exhibits are missing with the
policies for keeping them safe branded
as dire and there's a failed oversight
procedure for vetting those in sensitive
posts such as child protection
there's no doubt it's a hard-hitting
report and speaking personally it's a
difficult read at times um
professionally i find some of the issues
a little bit embarrassing
i take some comfort in the positivity
you know they've come down on the side
to say that we're not we're not
institutionally corrupt as an
organization which is a positive
i think they talk about advances we've
made in our homicide investigation and
and areas of vetting as well so there
are positives in there but we must we
must also be open to the fact that
there's a lot of criticism in there
daniel morgan was found dead in 1987 in
the car park of the golden lion pub here
in south london
what happened at this pub in sydney in
south london 35 years ago led to six
police investigations an inquest and an
eight-year public inquiry which
concluded last year that the
metropolitan police was institutionally
corrupt
today the inspectorate concluded the met
was not institutionally corrupt however
procedures for rooting out corrupt staff
were fundamentally flawed
daniel morgan's family who is suing the
met claimed a culture of corruption
continues
if you look at the way
the attitude that they have towards
corruption as displayed in this report
now that to me speaks since it says
institutional corruption
a completely nonchalant lackadaisical
approach to uh
police corruption and i would say that
there are cover-ups and you know the old
blue
line is closing somewhere every day
there were improvements in some areas
but not enough to make this report happy
reading for whoever takes over as the
new commissioner
jason farrell sky news